this video was made possible by hover
get your custom domain or email for 10%
off at hover.com
slash Wendover why do you walk outside
you know it's risky right don't you
value your life or rather how much do
you value your life could the answer be
infinite could your life be worth
everything to you after all most people
would say that they gain nothing from
losing their life and therefore the
value of their life to themselves must
be infinite but that can't be true
your life cannot be of infinite value to
yourself because if that were the case
you would never walk outside walking
outside is risky every time you set foot
on the sidewalk you elevate the chances
that imminently your life will end so
why do you walk outside risk is the
balance of negatives and positives for
you or anyone to consider a risk to be
acceptable the positives must outweigh
the negatives for example in a given
year an American has a 1 in 55,000
chance of dying by being hit by a car
while walking down the street if you
value your life infinitely that infinite
value would be multiplied by your chance
of death one in fifty five thousand per
year to create the total negative value
of walking outside but of course
infinity times anything is infinity so
you can't possibly value your life
infinitely because you do walk outside
you somehow decide that that one in
fifty five thousand chance of death is
worth it for whatever you gain from
walking down the street this is the
process of risk evaluation and for
absolutely every decision you make you
subconsciously balance the negatives and
positives let's ask another question
would you personally drive a car most
every person would answer yes we even
know how many people would answer yes
because two-thirds of all Americans have
a driver's license so follow-up question
would you personally go mountain biking
would you consider that to be too risky
to bring you a little too close to death
not all and probably not most but many
more would answer no this is something
that has come up time and time again as
mountain biking has gained popularity
and schools have tried to add it to
their roster of sports but parents and
administrators said no they said that it
was far too dangerous of a sport that
the risk of injury or death was
unacceptable however in a given year
the odds of death while driving for a
given licensed driver in the u.s. is 1
in 600 meanwhile the odds of death while
mountain biking for a given mountain
biker is about 1 in 30,000 is that what
you would have expected prior to these
statistics would you have earnestly
thought that this something you see
every day or possibly do every day is
more dangerous than something you watch
people do online in all most people
would say no so how are people's our
risk perceptions so wrong
what makes driving an acceptable risk to
nearly everyone but mountain biking an
unacceptable risk to many well it's
simple ingrained in our brains are
flawed processes for evaluating risk for
certain reasons what we fear will kill
us and what will actually kill us are
very very different these are the rules
of our flawed human risk evaluation
system rule 1 voluntary risks are more
acceptable than involuntary risks that
is to say people are far more tolerant
of risks that they can choose to engage
in than those they can't that's why most
of the population will happily drive a
car with a 1 in 600 annual risk of death
but if a food preservative was
introduced that had the same level of
risk that would be mass I'll cry in fact
studies have shown that people are
roughly 1,000 times more tolerant of
voluntary risk than involuntary the
perception of choice is powerful that
means that if measures are introduced
that make an involuntary risk seem
voluntary the risk is more tolerated
even
if those measures have little real
effects on the average overall risk this
gets tricky with activities that are
somewhere in between voluntary and
involuntary say for example a company is
polluting the air in a town this seems
like an involuntary risk you can't after
all choose to not breathe the polluted
air in however consider how
communication can reframe this the
factory owner might say you can always
move away or buy an air filter or stay
inside on bad air days if you give
people ways that seem to control their
personal exposure to an involuntary risk
they might start to believe that it is a
voluntary risk not only does this
potentially increase the tolerance of
those exposed to the risk it will also
increase the tolerance of the bystanders
not exposed they might think those
people are choosing to stay there and
not use an air filter and go outside the
blame is slowly shifted on the
individual rather than on the originator
of the risk the overall danger from
something can stay exactly the same but
give people a semblance of control over
it
and they will tolerate it rule to
acceptance is inversely proportional to
prevalence the more people who are
exposed to a given risk the less the
public will accept it we can accept the
huge risk of space travel with only a
tiny number of people partaking yet we
could not accept if air travel had the
same level of risk both are voluntary
activities but there are two parallel
effects taking place here fewer people
will engage in higher risk activities
and fewer people will tolerate high
exposure risks this effect is also why
the risk tolerance for things like
vaccines which are distributed to
hundreds of millions or billions of
people is so dramatically lower than the
risk tolerance of experimental medicines
which are distributed to a small and
select number of individuals
rule 3 disease is a yardstick it's been
shown that average human risk acceptance
roughly correlates to whether an
activity is more or less deadly than
one's chance of death from disease
what's possibly happening here is that
humans have accepted the likelihood of
their
death by the hands of disease so
partaking in anything riskier than
disease as unconscionable because it
then makes it more likely to die from
that other activity than disease it
changes one's statistically
predetermined end for example the
researcher who defined this rule found
that the average risk of death per hour
for a soldier fighting in the Vietnam
War was roughly equal to the average
risk of dying per hour from disease as a
human therefore the general public more
or less accepted the risk of those
fighting there this disregards the fact
that the risk for the individual
soldiers fighting in Vietnam of dying
from disease was at their average age
dramatically lower than the overall
population average which is skewed
heavily by those in old age but it
didn't matter because the public's
yardstick is disease riskier is not okay
less risky it's okay rule for novelty
increases perceived risk we fear what is
new and not yet understood as
understanding goes up perceived risk
goes down and his understanding goes
down perceived risk goes up for example
in one now famous 1970s study college
students were asked to rank 30
activities and technologies from most to
least risky simple as that
in the end on average they ranked
nuclear power as the riskiest of these
thirty above cars handguns smoking and
everything else then experts whose risk
perception was shown in separate
research to closely match real risk
ranked the same list of 32 them nuclear
power was the 20th most risky activity
or technology on the list meanwhile
non-nuclear electric power was 19th on
the college students list but ninth on
the experts list the college students
overestimated the risk of nuclear power
and underestimated the risk of electric
power so what's the difference between
nuclear and non-nuclear electric power
well normal electric power had been
widespread for a century at the time
when this research was done nuclear
power meanwhile was just gaining préval
this risk perception study was done
before the well-known meltdowns at Three
Mile Island and Chernobyl just single
digits of people had died directly from
nuclear energy incidents at the time yet
people feared it more than cars which
killed 50 thousand people in the u.s. in
the year when they were surveyed today
four decades later risk perception of
nuclear power is greatly reduced because
it is no longer new younger people now
learn how nuclear power works in school
and older people have a longer period of
evidence for the risk level of nuclear
power understanding leads to acceptance
rule 5 numbers are numbing the value of
saving one human life should be half of
the value of saving to human lives and
then the value of saving to human lives
should be half of saving for human lives
and so on and so forth that's intuitive
that makes sense each life is on average
worth saving as much as the next meaning
that a graph with the number of life
saved on the x-axis and the value of
life saved on the Y should look like
this a straight line there's even an
argument that's going a level deeper the
graph should look like this since a
large-scale loss of life has a more
widespread negative societal effect
losing a million lives would be more
than a million times worse than losing
one life for a society so the graph
should look either like this or this
however if you change this graph from
what humans logically agree on to what
they perceive psychologically research
shows it looks like this humans perceive
that saving the one-thousandth life is
less worth it than saving the first life
even though logically they are of equal
value this can partially explain how
people can tolerate mass-casualty
natural disasters or pandemics or
genocide with a little more concern than
they do small terrorist attacks
well this phenomenon doesn't make
logical sense it does make some
psychological sense because it lines up
with how people perceive other
quantifiable collections for example
humans value a dollar less the more
earn your first dollar is worth far more
than your millionth to your mind even
though a dollar is still worth a dollar
in the context of human life though this
is more destructive humans can't
comprehend mass tragedy through
statistics so they are not an effective
means of communication for those
purposes it is for this reason why
people might underestimate the risk that
causes mass casualty events these rules
and others all combine to create a
simple truth the way we as a collective
perceive risk is wrong we overestimate
the danger of low risk activities
underestimate the danger of high risk
activities we think things that we like
are less risky we can flate unfair
danger with higher danger this
perceptual package works so that they
perceive risk swings wildly above and
below actual risk we just can't trust
ourselves we can think honestly that a
risk has increased but it hasn't or that
it's decreased but it hasn't considering
that we the general public can also
reasonably know how risky something is
is exactly why life itself is risky
while science and statistics might know
the risk we don't so whether we're
actually engaging an acceptable risk is
a crapshoot normally this isn't
something worth stressing about our
flawed risk perception systems will
average out through time to make
something similar to real risk the only
time it's really worth considering is
when people are making decisions about
risk that affects others when people
somehow get to decide what risk others
face perception is dangerous because it
can silently and unknowingly eclipse
science statistics and fact
your online identity is now more visible
than ever so it's worth making sure you
present yourself right there are two key
first steps to that number one is having
a website with a custom domain and
number two is having an email hosted at
that domain hover helps you with both of
these steps starting with helping you
get a unique domain with there over 400
extensions they sell these at very fair
prices and then you can add a custom
email ending in that domain for a little
bit more even if you don't have the time
to set up your website now it's worth
getting the domain corresponding to your
name or business now because at any
moment someone could take it with hover
you can easily set it up to redirect to
your LinkedIn page or YouTube channel or
Twitter account or anything so that you
can easily direct people to your web
presence this is all made easier by the
fact that by going to hover comm slash
Wendover you can get 10% off hovers
already fair prices with your first
purchase and you'll be supporting
Wendover wall or added